down the ages past Allah sent his
Messengers to deliver humankind from
Darkness to light invite all to the way
of thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preachings and argue with them in the
ways that are best and most
gracious that's also the ongoing mission
of Islamic Research Foundation or irf
spreading the truth of Allah's final
message to
mankind founded in 1991
irf today offers some of the best
services and facilities in the world for
presenting an understanding of Islam in
an objective and scientific
way its programs are primarily focused
on correcting misconceptions and
promoting understanding of
Islam irf also imparts dawa training to
D to aptly convey The Message of
Islam irf has one of the most modern
Studios producing program s presenting
Islam which are beamed regularly on many
International TV channels in over 150
countries Dr Zakir Nik president of irf
reaching out across countries worldwide
from America to Europe to Africa to Asia
to Australia strives to clarify Islamic
viewpoints he dispels the many media
myths and anti-islamic prejudices
propagated the world over by
anti-islamic forces Dr Zakir Nik is a
medical doctor
he's acclaimed the world over for his
spontaneous and convincing replies to
questions posed by critics and
Skeptics during the question and answer
sessions after his
talks he is also renowned for his
verbatim quotes with references from
major religious scriptures of the
world Dr Zakir and other faculty of the
irf trained many dais in effective dawa
techniques
ir's website provides free dawa training
material for you to download and become
an effective Dai
yourself Dr zaker nik's talks are
available on audio and video cassettes
CDs and DVDs the world
over irf today is creating a change in
the hearts and minds of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims worldwide
towards a proper understanding and
respect for Islam have a question or
doubt about Islam and its teachings now
you know one of the best Resource
Centers to get convincing answers from
is Islamic Research Foundation 5658
tandel Street North dri Mumbai
400009 India phone 2373
6875 fax 9122 2373 0689 email Islam at
the rate
of.net for more information log on to
our website www.
IR f.net
[Music]
[Applause]
on behalf of the organizers Saba Islamic
media together with Pat ra and Islamic
Outreach
abim and Our Kind sponsors Remco
Malaysia IND Brad I'd like to welcome
you to tonight's
talk by our distinguished
speaker Dr Zaki Abdu Karim Nik who is
the president
of the Islamic Research Foundation
Mumbai
India he is known as the walking
computer on
not just the Quran but as we found out
today at I IU he's
also computer for the other scriptures
too he can quote from so many
scriptures you wonder what's the
megabytes of
his
brain and even my computer cannot access
when I press a button as quickly as he
can access his uh computer but
alhamdulillah that is the the glory and
the power of God if he wishes he create
among his beings those who have special
abilities and um Dr Zakir is one of
those blessed by Allah tala he's the
president of the Islamic Research
Foundation based in Mumbai India which
is a very active uh Daw organization
started by himself and helped by his uh
brother and also another fellow Doctor
Who will be
one of the teachers on Sunday for the
dawa training
program and uh they are internationally
active as you can see uh they have
produced many vide tapes and apparently
in uh Mumbai they have a 3our uh cable
uh TV program every day to the uh 16
million population of uh Mumbai and
something to be proud of uh that we and
other people around the world should
emulate in trying to propagate Islam he
has uh been to many many countries and
delivered hundreds of talks and this is
his second visit here he was here about
two years ago and I'm sure this will not
be the last um uh visit only time he is
here I I'm amazed at the pace that he
goes
through we have had um a series of talks
and tonight's uh topic as you can see on
the board is why the West is coming to
Islam as you are well aware that over
the last decade especially in Europe
Islam uh is virtually overrunning uh the
place in uh UK hundreds of churches have
been sold over to Muslims to make uh MOS
same thing in uh Germany a few years
back I read that the church the churches
there are worried because they don't
have many people coming to church where
they used to collect money and they now
uh do not have enough money to surv
most of the churches are now turned into
Community halls and likewise and Islam
is burgeoning uh in Germany and and the
countries around there and uh in America
you will all well know that Islam is
already the third largest religion after
Christianity and and Judaism what's more
is that among the the African Americans
or the color people uh Islam is is
becoming very popular
uh
before we hear Dr Zakir I'd like to
invite our special Kari all the way from
Japan to
recite uh some verses of Al Quran Surah
al-
MAA um and I will give you the
translations after his
rendition please welcome our Cory
abduli or Haruka Kimura
he's an Islamic teacher and Dai from
Japan and holds a ba in DAW and from
Madina Islamic
University
alhamdulillah and he will read al- MAA
Surah Al MAA vers 78 to 86 inshallah
[Music]
Mar
C
[Music]
w
let
[Music]
be
y
[Music]
for for
curses were pronounced on those among
the children of Israel who rejected
Faith by the Tongue of David and of
Jesus the son of Mary because they
disobeyed and persisted in excesses nor
did they forbid one another the
iniquities which they committed evil
indeed were the Deeds which they
did thou sees many of them turning in
Friendship to the
unbelievers evil indeed are the works
which their souls have sent forward
before them that Allah's wroth is on
them and in torment will they abide If
Only They had believed in Allah in the
prophet and in what has been revealed to
them never would they have taken them
for friends and protectors but most of
them are rebellious
wrongdoers strongest among men in enmity
to the Believers will thou find the Jews
and the pagans and nearest among them in
love to the Believers will thou find
those who say we are Christians because
amongst these are men devoted to
learning and men who have renounced the
world and they are not arrogant and when
they listen to the Revelation received
by the messenger thou will see their
eyes overflowing with tears for they
recognize the truth they pray our Lord
we believe write us down among the
witnesses what cause can we have not to
believe in Allah and the truth which has
come to us seeing that we long for our
Lord to admit us to the company of the
righteous and for this their prayer has
Allah rewarded them with gance with
rivers flowing underneath the Eternal
home such is the recompense of of those
who do good but those who reject faith
and bely our signs they shall be
Companions of
hellare so thank you brother
ABD without further Ado I will call upon
uh
Dr alhamdulillah
[Music]
respected chairman my respected elders
and my dear brothers and sisters I
welcome all of you with the Islamic
greetings may peace mercy and blessings
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala be on all of
you the topic of today evening's talk is
in a form of a
question why the West is coming to
Islam and if you have to give the reply
in just one sentence the answer is the
West is coming to Islam because Islam
has the solutions to the problems of the
West the Western
World mainly the society
it caters to certain
needs of the
body it caters to the physical needs of
the
body there are several religions most of
them which only cater to the spiritual
aspect that's the
soul but
alhamdulillah Islam is a religion which
has got a dual role it caters to the
physical aspect of the body body as well
as the spiritual need of the Soul it has
a dual role it caters to the body as
well as the
soul Islam comes from the root word
Salam which means peace it also means
submitting your will to Allah subhana wa
ta'ala to almighty God in short Islam
means peace acquired by submitting your
will to Allah subhana wa ta'ala to
Mighty
God the Glorious
Quran is the last and final revelation
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala which was
revealed to the last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad sallallahu Ali wasallam
the Glorious Quran is the most positive
book in the world it's a proclamation to
humanity it's a fountain of mercy and
wisdom it's a warning to the
heedless a guide to the eron
an assurance to those in doubt a Solace
to the suffering and a hope to those in
despair let us analyze today the reasons
why the West is coming to
Islam one of the important reason is
that the Western
world is
open-minded their minds aren't closed
they're
broad-minded and neither are the
conservative
like many other parts of the
world
and that's the reason that I say when
people ask me the question that I keep
on traveling by the grace of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala to different parts of
the
world how is the response to the talks
Etc so I tell them that our job is to
deliver the message of Allah subhana wa
taala it is he who gives a Allah says in
surash chapter 88 verse number
21 for you have to admonish you are not
a manager of aair or people's thing but
I tell them that there is a lot of
difference between the Western world and
the Eastern world and if suppose I tell
them that if one
non-muslim in the Eastern World
especially the country where I come from
that is India if one non-muslim in India
accepts Islam
it is equivalent to 50 non-muslims
accepting Islam in the western world
that doesn't mean one Indian is so
Superior it is 50 times more Superior
than the West no it's not that what I'm
trying to tell them is that the
society in the East especially India it
is
conservative it's
narrow-minded even if a person likes the
teachings of Islam it's very difficult
for him to accept
Islam
because he has several problems even if
he likes Islam he's afraid of the
society the society May boycott him he
may have economic
problems they may be danger to his life
he may have social problems therefore
even if a person likes Islam in India it
is very difficult for him to accept
Islam because the society is
conservative and the people they are
narrow as compared to the westerners but
that is no excuse for the non-muslims in
India for not to accept Islam they will
be held responsible for
that as compared to the
westerners I keep on giving talks
alhamdulillah in Middle East and various
parts of the world some westerners keep
on following me and after a couple of
lectures I just even after one lecture
alhamdulillah they like Islam so much
that they accept at the end of The Talk
which is not the case in Bombay have to
slog out you know and have to really for
months and years together finally it's
not because of the efforts of the D that
the person accepts Islam is because
Allah subhana tala gives them and gives
them courage so first reason I would say
the westerners are more broadminded
because in the same family the
father can be a Christian but he would
not mind if the children they accept
Islam you yet they can live under the
same roof which is not the case in
India hardly will you find that the
father belongs to a different religion
and the children belong to different
religion you will not find such a
family therefore I say that the
westerners are more broadminded
and they are not conservative as far as
religion is
concerned the other important reason is
the Western world it is advanced in the
field of science and technology know the
West alhamdulillah at least in this age
it has advanced in the field of science
and
technology and according to Albert
Einstein he
said that science without religion is
lame and religion without science is
blind and the westerners they consider
science at the ytic the ultimate Yas to
judge anything is science
s and
alhamdulillah Quran speaks several
things about science though Quran is not
a book of signs s c i e n c e it's a
book of signs s i
gns and there are more than 6,000 signs
ayats in the Glorious Quran out of which
more than a thousand speak about
signs those of you who have heard my
talk I've given the talk on Quran and
modern science compatible or
incompatible or Quran and modern science
conflict or conciliation which proves
alhamdulillah that the Quran is far
superior to science so with the help of
using the yasti of the westerners we can
prove our yashik which is Quran Which is
far superior than science has mentioned
what they have discovered today, 1400
years ago since they advanced in the
field of science and technology and if
we speak with them
with hikma alhamdulillah they realize
that Quran is far superior to science
and many of them come to
Islam thirdly alhamdulillah the
westerners they like to reason
out they won't just accept anything on
face value they will reason out they
will
investigate and then only will they be
convinced they are not a group of
people who believe in Superstition most
of them neither do they adhere to Blind
beliefs and that's exactly what the
Quran says and Quran shows a technique
how to dawa in chapter number 16 verse
number 125 he
says that is invite all to the way of
thy Lord with wisdom and beautiful
preaching and argue with them and reason
with them in the ways that are best and
most gracious Quran always encourages
reasoning no one of the Quran says in
several places including Bak chapter
number 2 verse number
242 so that you may understand the Quran
wants the people to understand the Quran
and then accept
it the Quran says in Surah ibraim
chapter number 14
verse number 52 that here is a message
for the humankind let them take warning
there from let them know there is one
God and let the men of understanding
take heed Quran says let the men of
understanding take
heed and alhamdulillah many of the
westerners they are men of
understanding and they always like to
question anything until they are
convinced they will not accepted that's
the reason if you read the Quran the
Quran is also a sort of a question
answer book no wonder if you read the
Quran it's
mentioned they say 330 times they say
they ask and the Quran says 33 times
tell it's a sort of a question answer
book for example they the concerning vne
and gambling and the Quran gives the
answer they are the concerning new moon
and the Quran says cool it starts
it satisfies the intellectual of a
person and
today in most parts of the world
especially the West part of the world
you know people are very busy there are
so many new philosophies and new things
coming up that time doesn't permit us to
analyze
everything the westerners and the people
around the world they're very busy so
now if you bring up a new Theory or a
new
hypothesis or a new philosophy
first they ask you that do you
have any way to prove your theory wrong
or do you have any way to prove your
philosophy wrong it's known as
falsification
test the westerners they believe in the
falsification test means any Theory you
bring forth if you want us to analyze
that theory first show us a way how to
prove your theory wrong what will we do
that will prove your theory wrong then
we'll analyze it otherwise there are
thousands of things people are bringing
up new things where do we have the time
to analyze everything if you have a way
to prove your theory wrong we will do
that and prove it wrong if you can't
then we'll agree with your theory that's
the reason Albert Einstein when he
propounded his the of Relativity he had
three ways he said to prove my theory
wrong do these three things and Theory
will be proved wrong and don't accept it
so for 6 years they tested it out and
they agreed and then but natural he got
the Nobel
Prize Quran is the only religious book
and Islam is the only religion which has
this falsification
test and I've have discussed various
falsification test in my cassette is the
Quran God's word I'll just mention one
of them which mainly caters to the
Western
mind the Glorious Quran says in number 4
verse number
82 that do they not consider the Quran
with care do they not Ponder over the
Quran with care had it been from anyone
besides Allah there would have been many
discrepancies there would have been many
contradictions in it so if you want to
prove the Quran wrong you take out a
single discrepancy the Quran is proved
wrong if you want to say Quran is not a
word of God you take out a contradiction
Quran will be proved wrong it is so easy
just take out one mistake in the Quran
and the Quran will be proved wrong so
easy just go through the book will take
you a few hours or a couple of days take
out the mistake and I'll agree the Quran
is wrong it is presenting a
falsification
test throughout the ages there are
falsification test given by the Quran
but for this age this test is there
which was applicable even that time but
today it's more applicable you know
because today is the age of Science and
Technology previously was the age of
literature poetry Etc it had different
falsification test for that time which
is even applicable today but this
particular one is applicable for the
westerners not that westerners didn't
right you have several critics of Islam
giv giv hundreds of alleged
contradictions alleged scientific errors
all of which are actually nothing but
falsehood because if you know more about
science as Francis bacin said that
little knowledge of science makes you an
atheist but an indepth knowledge of
science makes you a believer in God
that's the reason today the Western
World they are eliminating models of God
but they are not eliminating
God as I mentioned that Islam has the
solutions to the problems of the West
time doesn't permit us to discuss all
the problems and solutions which Islam
has we'll just pick up a few and discuss
a few of
them as I
mentioned that the Western world is
drowned in materialism it's a
materialistic world you know more
concerned about trying to see the
welfare of the body so much that they
have been drowned in
materialism and Quran has a solution
Quran says in Surah chapter number 9
verse number 34 and 35 it says that
spend of your wealth in the way of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
and give a warning to those people who
bury gold and silver and spend it not in
the way of Allah those who hold their
gold and silver and spend it not in the
way of Allah announc to them a grievous
penalty that fire will be produced from
the wealth which they
afforded it will be heated in the
Hellfire and on the day of judgment
they'll be branded with it on the
forehead on the flanks and on the
back and the Quran says that this life
is a test for the
Hereafter in Sur M chap 67 verse number
two that Allah subhana wa ta'ala has
created death and life to test which of
you is good in
deeds and the Quran says in Iman 3 vers
that every soul shall have a taste of
death the final recompense shall be paid
on the day of
judgment and anyone who enters the
garden that is jna and is kept away from
the Hellfire he would have achieved the
purpose of this life for this life is
but goods and Chatters of deception
Quran says this life people are running
after materialism it's a good of chatter
and deception but a person who safe from
the Hellfire and enters the garden would
have achieved the objective of this
life people spend too much money
Etc and Quran has a solution for the
spend thrifts Quran
says in is chapter number 17
verse number 26 and
27 that spend not your
wealth like that of a spend Thrift do
not be a spend Thrift because spend
thrifts are the brothers of the devil
that mean if you spend excessively you
are a brother of the
devil and
today throughout the world including the
Western World you
have a system that in order to hold more
wealth and to gain more wealth you use
your wealth to eat other people's wealth
in English it's called as
bribing the Quran says in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number 188 that
squand not your wealth on vanities and
do not use your wealth in order to use
it as baits to
judges so that you may eat other
people's wealth
that means do not use your wealth as a
bribe as bit to judges so that you may
eat other people's wealth bribing is
prohibited in
Islam and the Quran
says in Surah huat chapter 49 verse
number 11 and 12 that let not one group
of men laugh at the others you may never
know the latter may be better than the
former let not one group of women laugh
at the other you may never know the lat
may be better than the
former do not call each other by
nicknames don't be sarcastic to one
another avoid suspicion for suspicion in
some cases is a sin do not spy on one
another do not backbite do not call each
other by nicknames and do not slander
behind the backs do not
backbite are you ready to eat the dead
meat of your brother the Quran says that
if you backbite if you speak against
somebody's back it's as though you're
eating the dead meat of your
brother and eating dead meat is
prohibited in the Quran speaking bad
about someone without proof slandering
him without proof is prohibited in Islam
slandering someone behind his back when
he doesn't have an opportunity to
clarify is double sin eating dead meat
is a sin eating dead meat of your
brother the cannibals who eat meat even
they don't eat the meat of their own
brother so backbiting is as good as
eating the dead meat of your brother and
Quran says n you would abor it this
backbiting and slandering in the Garb of
freedom of expression you know hidden
behind the term freedom of expression
you find it very prevalent
throughout the Western World you know
people abusing each other slandering
each other inite commas freedom of
expression the Quran says in chapter 104
verse number one
W to every kind of Scandal monger and
backbite the problem
today which the West is facing and it
has also seen to it that the other parts
are facing because of it is RBA is
interest today the Western world is in
problem because of riba because of
interest and they seen to it that they
have passed this disease even to the
other parts of the world it
started in England by the king of
England he said that you give money I
will keep it with you and then I will
give you interest fixed interest on it
and that's how the present interest
based banking system started and they
have spread this fever this disease
throughout the
world the Quran mentions about riba the
word riba is given in the Quran in no
less than eight different
times it's mentioned in Surah Al Imran
chapter number three verse number 130 in
Surah n chter number 4 verse number 161
it's mentioned in Sur room CH number
30:39 thce in Surah Bak chapter number 2
verse number 275 it's also mentioned Sur
Bak chapter number 2 verse number 276
and in Sur Bak CH number 2 verse number
278 the word is mentioned in the
Glorious Quran no less than eight
times and why it is Haram Etc I've given
the talk on interest free economy
promulgated by the Quran
for people who want to know the reason
why Islam has prohibited RBA and the
riba includes interest over and above
people say that oh no RBA doesn't
include interest modern interest it only
means Usery and I've described this in
detail people can a of my video C said
interest free economy by the Quran which
gives more detail time doesn't permit us
to go into the minute details of
economics in this talk but just like to
give the translation of two verses of
the Quran that is Bak CH 2 verse 27 279
which says that oh you believe give up
your demands of RBA of
interest and if you give not your
demands of riba Interest take notice of
a from Allah and hiso mean anyone who
deals with interest Allah and his rasool
will wage a war against
you there are various sins mentioned in
the Glorious Quran which are big sins
but this particular sin besides being a
grave sin It also says that anyone who
deals with interest Allah and his rasool
will wage a war against you if you deal
with interest you're challenging Allah
and his rasool for a
war
furthermore if you see in the Western
World we have people
especially the children they don't
respect the
parents it's more in the western world
as compared to the Eastern
world
and
nowadays in the new era you have special
child abuse cell the Western world in
America and in other European
countries you can phone the police the
special child abuse cell and you can
even threaten your parents if your
parents called you too much you can you
better be careful other I'll dial that
number and the parents they understand
okay now he means business you're giving
right to everyone rights are there in
Islam they have even given rights to
Children the maximum is in Islam but the
Quran
says in 4: 171 do not commit excesses in
your
religion but natural children should be
protected but now in the gab of
protection the children they are
threatening they are blackmailing the
parents if they want
something and if the parents don't give
they can blackmail you can even give
fake calls no problem the police will
come May harass the parent may not
arrest them but they can be
problems several places in the Quran
says that you should respect your
parents several places and L man CH
number 31 verse number 14 and number 46
verse number 15 and Anam 6 ver 151
several places but specifically it
says in Surah is chapter number 17 verse
number 23 and 24 it says that after
worship of Allah subhana wa taala the
next duty is respecting your parents the
Quran says in Surah is 17: 23 and 24
that Allah has ordained for you that you
worship none but me and that you be kind
to your parents and if any one of them
or both of them Reach old age do not
even say a word of contempt don't even
say o to
them you can't even say o to
them but lower to them your wing of
humility and address them with honor and
pray to the Lord that cherish them as
they cherished me in childhood imagine
the Quran says if any one or both of
your parents reach old age you cannot
even say of to them in the Western World
you have the concept of old age homes
where the parent gets old put them in to
the old age home there's no concept of
old age home in Islam because the duty
of the
children and the relatives to look after
the elderly people they have to respect
them they have to love them they have to
behave with them with compassion unlike
the Western World which moment a child
gets an adult the parents may have
looked after the child but moment he
feels he can stand on his own two
feet then he shows his back to the
parents
the common problem which is there in the
western world is
adultery it is
fornication and the Glorious Quran
says in is chapter number 17 verse
number 32 that come not close to
adultery for it is an evil opening road
to other evils adultery is an evil
opening roads to other evils that's the
reason
in Islam marriage is
compos there is no monasticism in
Islam and our beloved Prophet mamm
wasallam said it's mentioned bukari Vol
number s in the book of nikah chapter
number three Hadith number four that oh
young people Whoever has the means to
get married should get
married and I beloved Prophet said that
anyone who marries completes half his
de one question answer time somebody
asked me that does it mean that if I
married twice I complete my full
Dean what did the prophet mean by saying
marriage completes half your Dean what
he
meant
that marriage prevents you from
promiscuity from homosexuality from
fornication which are half the evil in
the
society only if you marry do you have an
opportunity to be a husband or wife only
if you marry do you have have an
opportunity to be a father or a mother
which are very important duties in Islam
therefore the Quran says that marriage
is a m a secret Covenant inah chapter
number 4 verse number
21 Allah subh says in Sur Room chapter
number 30 verse number 21 that amongst
his signs he has made for you m of like
nature so that you may dwell in them
with tranquility and he has put love and
mercy between your hearts marriage the
compass in
Islam today one of the biggest problem
that the Western world is facing which
is not so much in the eastern part of
the world is the surplus of
women you have more women in the Western
World in the Eastern world the reason is
because of female
infanticide if this evil practice stops
even in the Eastern world this problem
will be
there if you analyze the glor Quran says
and gives the solution for this problem
in Surah chapter number four verse
number three that marry woman have a
choice in two threes or fours but if you
can't do justice marry only
one that means a person can marry two
threes or fours if he can do justice if
he can't marry only one but at the same
time the Quran says in N
4:29 it is impossible for you to do
justice between your wives so do not
turn away from them
altogether here what the Quran is
referring to that where it comes to
justice as love is concerned it's
difficult it's
impossible to love both your wies
equally even a mother she loves her
children but no mother can say that I
love 100% exactly both my children same
can't be possible she can love both the
children alhamdulillah very much but no
mother can say I love exactly both my
children at the same level it's not
possible there has to be some Apollo but
overall there should not be Injustice
the Quran says it's impossible to
Justice between your wives but don't
turn away from them altogether regarding
the other things where it comes to money
time Etc you should be just between your
wies if you buy one house for your wife
the second wife get the same house so
the Quran says you're only allowed to
marry more than one wife if you can do
justice if you can't do justice you
cannot many people think that marry more
than one wife is compulsory in Islam
that's a misconception in Islam there
are five categories of dos and don'ts
first is f which is compulsory second is
must that is recommended or encouraged
third is muah that's optional fourth is
Mak that is discouraged and the fifth is
Haram that is
prohibited polygen a man allowed to
marry more than one wife comes in the
category of optional the middle
category there's no words in the Quran
saying that if you marry more than one
wife you get
more now let's analyze why does Quran
give the permission that under certain
circumstances you can have more than one
wife by nature men and women are born in
equal proportion male and female they're
born in equal
proportion but during the Pediatric age
itself if you ask any pediatrician he
will tell you that the female child can
fight the germs and diseases much better
than the male child so in pediatric age
itself there are more male children
dying than female children so in the
Pediatric age itself the female
population is more than the male
population as life goes on death takes
place due to accident cigarette smoking
Wars Etc in all these cases more male
are dying as compared to female so today
in the world there is more female
population as compared to male
population it's only in certain
countries like India
that the male population is more than
the female population and as I said it
is because of female infanticide and
according to a report of BBC by Emily
beckan on the program assignment the
topic was let her die she said that
every day more than 3,000 fetuses are
being aborted in India alone after they
identified that they're females if you
multiply this figure by 365 the number
of days in a year more than 1 million
fetes are being aborted every year in
India after the end of that they're
females if you stop this evil practice
even in India and some other countries
the female population will exceed the
male
population according to
statistics USA alone has 7.8 million
females more than
male New York alone has 1 million
females more than M out of the
population of New York the statistics
tell us one3 are gays
gays means site me K that means they
wouldn't like to have female life
Partners there are more than 25 million
gays
sodomites in America in USA and another
problem 25
million in UK alone there are 4 million
females more than
male in Germany alone there are 5
million females more than male in Russia
alone there are 9 million females more
than male and Allah subhana tal knows
alone how many millions of females are
there more than males throughout the
world suppose I agree with the Western
philosophy or non-muslim who says that
one man should only marry one woman and
suppose my sister happens to live in
America and suppose the market is
saturated that every man has already
taken a woman for
himself yet there'll be 30 million
females who will not find life partners
7.8 million as it is the excess and the
25 million G if you add it to
them there are more than 30 million
females who will not find life Partners
now the only option
remaining for my sister I suppose your
sister happens to be in America and
she's that unfortunate one who has not
found a life partner if she can find a
man who's not married alhamdulillah grab
him but suppose the market is
saturated what she will do the only
option remaining for her is that she
either marries a who already has a wife
or she becomes public
property know people say public property
Dr Zak using such a harsh word I'm
saying that the most sophisticated words
that I can use is public property you
know I cannot use other words because
I'm a
d public property there's no third
option and any modest woman would say
she would prefer the first becoming the
wife of a man who already has a wife
than to become public
property and you know in the western
world it's very common people have
Mystic very
common the statistics of USA tell us
that on average one man has eight
different sexual partners before he
settles down with one life partner some
may have 10 some may have 20 some may
have 30 some may have less two or one on
average eight different sexual life
Partners before he settles down with one
permanent
one having a mistress is no problem you
can have 1 10 20 30 no problem but if
you ask any woman when a woman becomes a
mistress she doesn't have honor she's
degraded she doesn't have any rights as
compared to a
woman when a woman is the second wife of
a man she gets honor she gets respect
she gets a
rights we in Islam alhamdulillah give
the women the due rights for the Western
World they can easily agree with the
philosophy of a man having several
Mystics but a person having more than
one wife it doesn't go down the
throat Islam has a solution to the
problems of
humankind if you analyze most of the
major religions they speak good things
don't Rob don't cheat Etc Islam says the
same but the difference between Islam
and the other religion is that Islam
besides speaking good things it shows
you a way how to achieve that state of
goodness how to achieve that state in
which these particular principles laws
can be
followed for
example all the major religions
including the Western world says that a
person should not Rob if you read the
constitution of America and Europe it
says that a citizen should not Rob and
if he robs there are certain remedies
given but it's not showing its
colors Islam to says that you should not
robam but Islam has a solution it shows
you a way how to achieve that state in
which people will not robam Islam has a
system of zakat that is every rich
person who has a saving of more than the
nisab level 85 grams of gold he should
give 2.5% of that saving in charity
every lunar year if every rich person
gives zakat poverty will be eradicated
from this world there will not be a
single human being who will die of
hunger and after this the Quran says in
Surah MAA chapter number 5 verse number
38 as to the thief be it a man or a
woman chop of his or her hand as a
punishment from Allah subhana tala